this is so creepy so why do you like it
I'm trying to figure this out I just
keep watching it's like you are are so
scary yeah but so normal-seeming so tell
me about dynamics so normal-seeming yeah
I don't know well he is normal I am
normal
I mean how the when it's normal-seeming
that's just me kind of just being normal
terribly difficult and then I just say
you had to think about it like well you
know this is a fictional character it
would have had something more concrete
to draw from if it was if it was a real
character but he's not so so I think I
was always wondering should I should I
be making him if someone's really
capable of of X Shh is he also capable
of Y want Y being charming and normal
and I guess you know it was always just
to sort of balance between that those
two things like you know in a way I mean
I'm grossly oversimplifying it but well
I could never know about the abnormality
yeah there are a lot of scary scenes but
the one
but the barfing scene yeah oh yeah
really creeped me out
tell me about shooting that that of all
scenes really right yeah yeah that's
right it's only the first two of us the
first episode the barfing scene well
first of all that day I laid on from New
York City subway track for basically
yeah all day and there's no way to fake
that she did it it was like foul and
brave so how many people can say that
I'm in live to survive to tell the tale
yeah actually that's a and then I had to
hold pea soup in my mouth mm-hmm while
we spit it on me yeah it was satisfying
very long day it was very fun to shoot
in the subway it was a unique New York
experience the scary part of this whole
show - is the access to people's bones
and you know the kind of stalking has
that made you change how you handle your
own laptops and is it I think I realized
how disciplined I am with social media
because I just because having been on a
show like Gossip Girl and in the public
eye for some time especially as like a
young adult like in my 20s I was never
allowed to develop this sort of
relationship with social media we're
like I you know I knew I think I felt
very acutely what it's like to be
infringed upon maybe in your privacy and
so I so I very early on just didn't do
that to other people like just casually
stalking the way people talk about it
you don't do that I don't actually I
think it's even if I have the desire to
I just don't even think of it as a pret
it's like I just and I actually don't
have the desire to because I don't think
of it as an option so if the funny thing
is is that in that way I don't even know
I always I don't know if you remember
but when we were shooting I would always
say like the stuff where Joe's tweeting
and light acting like other people I'm
just like what am I even whatever just
you got it okay and I'm treating and
cool it does I didn't relate to it so
that particular element the same way you
know the last job was on it I it was
it's something that escaped me in that
particular respect as well it's a good
reminder that people's profiles are not
their whole self I mean not even
anywhere close to their real-life self
and so I always remind myself of that
when I'm stalking people
[Laughter]